haha welcome welcome hello welcome to
this um scam factory called grace and
help ik I am in another hotel room haha
because we are on the second sorry I
just took a second to take in that laugh
it just happened I'm so sorry memory and
I are on the second leg of our hail USA
travel series which if you haven't
subscribed to go over to youtube.com
slash astronauts one it and subscribe to
it it's very exciting
so I we've been traveling all day today
and doing really fun things so I hadn't
had a chance to edit chase video so I'm
doing it right now I just want to give
you a little prelude to it it's just a
bunch of footage from VidCon this
weekend the YouTube convention that
happened in Anaheim I just shot some
random stuff from it I did a very um
mediocre to poor job of shooting things
and remembering to shoot things so I
thought that I would just share those
clips with you guys
what a bunch of idiots I think I
realized that there's more people on the
end of this and they're not for you
they're really interested in how my
VidCon work okay guys just so you know
or just so I can inform you this is so
stupid but I'm going to tell you all
about it I love if you don't know
already ordering too much room service
and then packing it all up and then
putting it in front of someone else's
door and I two nights ago
put all of my room service that had been
compiled over two nights in front of my
next-door neighbor's door here at VidCon
and I found out recently via Alfie's
vlog that my next-door neighbor is Joyce
Vaughn and I'd put two nights with the
Roosters in front of his door knee
though there was some fan pranking him
guys look how much Troy had for dinner
so he has taken the room-service eating
it and then left the garbage outside so
I ordered way too much Mexican food
tonight pan to the Mexican food so
tonight I'm going to take all this
Mexican food and put it back in front of
Troy's door this is gonna be so great
I haven't oh I'm gonna reuse that tray
okay ready cue the montage are we trying
to pack up all this Mexican food
creepy the way your Liz very menacing
thank you
how do practicing my menacing look at
home so I'm bowling with my brother
right now and the deal was that if he
won last game areas oh you can't do that
no I'm
I am videoing this to get I don't
understand what's happening
I am going again no I'm explaining in my
video tomorrow that you tweeted for me
because you can't do that get out of
here no dude you're such a strong
Florence Nightingale opinion I'll even
let it was all okay would have a still
use legend and I lost the first game
which meant that Tim won
and so Tim tweeted from my account
without me letting guys know Florence
Nightingale not for me from Tim yeah she
brought statistical test to medical
practice she brought like actual using
numerical data to analyze health what
did you happen that work I don't know
but I do know that at room service got
Troy's food before twice all his food
there anything Troy's had [ __ ] you to
them and that he's a little diva and a
very search boy I didn't think it
through
I don't know is sincerely don't know I
do know I need to take a shower
hahaha what are you looking at wait wait
wait wait
Vidya nine uh nice butter the butter
yeah well I want to buy one you were
[ __ ] honestly though it was a moment